un match pour se relancer après deux
défaites en National 3 plaisirs les clés
recevez le dernier du classement
avranches granville à l'occasion de la
15e journée du championnat pourtant ce
sont les visiteurs qui prennent
rapidement les devants dans la partie
les ibunaux à peine à trouver des
solutions et perdent 15 à 13 à la pause
c'était un peu compliqué au début du
match on a on a mis un peu de temps à se
mettre dedans
défensivement on a trouvé les bonnes
solutions pour les contrées mais en
concrétisait pas assez nos actions en
contre-attaque c'était une première
mi-temps qui était pas terrible vraiment
on a fait une entame de bâche où on
prend 4 ans je crois ou peut-être 5 5 1
peut-être quelque chose comme ça donc ça
a été vraiment très dur c'est une équipe
qui a plus rien à jouer dans le
championnat donc ce qui joue ultra
décomplexé ça nous a posé quelques
problèmes en seconde période plaisir les
clés plus conquérant et prend enfin
l'avantage et la 17e minute de la
seconde période avranches granville
n'arrive pas à suivre la cadence des
locaux et ne reviendra pas dans le match
score final 30 à 24 j'ai retrouvé un
système défensif plus intéressant et
offensivement on a été pour une fois
très bon en deuxième mi-temps on a
imposé le rythme aussi bien en défense
que en attaque on a passé beaucoup moins
de temps en attaque placé ce qui nous
arrange parce que c'est un peu notre
difficulté cette saison on a resserré
les rangs en défense avec beaucoup de
récupération de balles c'est ce qui nous
a permis de refaire le retard et ensuite
de passer devant et après encore une
fois comme ils ont plus rien à jouer
dans le championnat derrière ça a été
plus facile une fois qu'on était devant
ils ont un peu lâché avec cette victoire
les Yvelinois se retrouvent à la 8e
place du championnat de National 3 leur
prochain match est programmé le samedi
25 mars à l'extérieur contre
Bois-Colombes